here at Yale we're committed to
improving the world today and for future
Generations through outstanding research
and scholarship education preservation
and practice
generations of generous alumni and
friends have through their financial
support ensure that we can fulfill this
commitment helping us to sustain current
programming fund new Ambitions and
guarantee that future Generations May
pursue Excellence just as we do today
our donor's generosity established
Yale's endowment which with careful
stewardship provides long-term and
stable source of revenue for the
University and underpins the
sustainability of Yale's Mission and the
Fulfillment of our strategic vision
this video will explain how the
endowment Works what restrictions are
placed on its use and its impact on the
University and Beyond
the university endowment is made up of
almost 8 000 different accounts these
are contributions that have been made by
individuals over the decades
and some of them are restricted in their
use and that the donor had a particular
interest in mind of how they wanted to
support the university that might be for
a scholarship it might be for a
particular unit or department and so
these would be restricted endowments and
about 75 percent of the total university
endowment is under these restricted
accounts so we have an obligation as a
university to utilize the funds in a way
consistent with how the uh the donor
made their contribution and we do that
we do that very carefully which means
that although the endowment is quite
large it is also quite restricted as we
utilize those funds for various parts of
the University operation endowment
income contributes a third of the
revenue that comprises the annual
operating budget making it the
University's largest revenue source
over the course of a decade the
university spends half of the value of
the endowment so an endowment is really
very different than a savings account if
you think about a Family Savings Account
families save usually to make a big
expenditure so they might be saving to
buy a house or a car or pay for their
children's education or they might be
saving for an emergency kind of an
emergency fund But ultimately that those
savings are meant to be spent at some
point and that's not the case with an
endowment an endowment is invested in
the earnings on the endowment can be
spent but the endowment itself can't be
James Tobin developed the idea of
intergenerational equity James Tobin was
a economics professor at Yale and a
Nobel Prize winner and also my
macroeconomics professor in graduate
school at Yale and it was the notion
that an institution like Yale has an
obligation to today's students and
Scholars but also to maintaining that
Excellence over time and making sure
that it has the resources for future
Scholars and students so by spending
from the earnings you support the
mission of the institution not just
today but in the future
[Music]
the management of the endowment is is a
team effort obviously the broader
Administration and the El Corporation
are involved in overseeing it but the
day-to-day management of the endowment
is run by the Investments office which
I'm fortunate enough to to lead that
group of people which is largely made up
of Yale alumni was drawn here for a
number of reasons I think the collegial
culture the ethically scrupulous
decision making that I think we've been
known for for a long time and then
finally just the ability to give back to
the mission of the institution that
again so many of us benefit from
ourselves as students brought together
this group of people who run the
Endowment for the benefit of the
community
our strategy is actually fairly simple
it's to take a long-term approach that's
one of the core advantages we have in
the market as a multi-hundred year old
institution that expects to be around
for a while still relative to other
players who might be looking at quarter
to quarter you know results in the
financial markets we can take a longer
term approach and partner with some of
the best investors in the world over a
30-year period Yale's investment
strategy has added over 30 billion
dollars in value relative to a passive
strategy that would allocate sixty
percent of its Holdings to stocks and
forty percent to bonds each year Yale
aims to spend five and a quarter percent
of the endowment's value the amount
projected to be sustainable given
reasonable long-term growth expectations
in the endowment's investment returns
because long-term higher education
inflation averages about four percent a
year the endowment needs to grow by
approximately nine and a quarter percent
each year net of gifts and transfers in
order to maintain its real value while
also providing operating funds to the
university the endowment spending policy
balances to go goals and those goals are
kind of In conflict with one another
on the one hand we want steady funding
for the programs and operations that the
faculty staff and students depend on and
on the other hand eventually the
spending that we have has to reflect the
resources we have that is the value of
the endowment the endowment spending
rule balances those two goals by
smoothing fluctuations in the value of
the endowment and slowing the
incorporation of those changes in the
value of the endowment into the budget
the way the smoothing works is that
every year the spending from the
endowment is calculated and we have a
Target spending rate of 5.25 percent of
the endowment's value the smoothing
equation calculates 20 of each Year's
endowment spending by applying the
target spending rate 5.25 percent to the
endowments fiscal year-end market value
from two fiscal years prior the other
eighty percent comes from the previous
year's spending
smoothing rule means that the 40.2
percent return in 2021 isn't reflected
as a 40.2 percent increase in spending
the next year
instead it's averaged into the budget
over time beginning with the fiscal year
2023 budget that year the endowment will
provide 1.7 billion dollars to the
annual budget
an increase of about 170 million dollars
or about 10 percent over the previous
year it would also work the other way
say the endowment were to experience a
negative 25 return one year which is
what happened in fiscal year 2009.
the effect of that return wouldn't be
felt in the endowment spending for two
years
allowing the budgeting process to make
gradual adjustments rather than more
severe disruptions to the University's
core Mission and even then it would be
averaged in overtime just as positive
returns are so that endowment spending
would decrease by a much smaller
percentage in the short run than the
investment return might suggest
foreign
[Music]
s every aspect of the University
everything from scholarships that are
provided to students so they can study
here so the salaries that support the
faculty and staff that work here you see
that in the form of new buildings that
have been constructed such as the
humanities quadrangle that recently
opened but it's not just buildings it's
also the academic side of things what
happens in our offices what happens in
our libraries what happens in our
Laboratories so the idea of being able
to build a quantum computer is something
that is supported by the endowment
finding solutions to the various aspects
of climate change that are facing our
planet that is supported by the
endowment trying to understand human
cognition and how the brain functions
that's part of what is supported by the
endowment so as you think about the
university basically every aspect of it
in some form or another is supported by
these endowment funds that we have
available to us if you ask the question
how much does it actually cost to
provide an undergraduate education at
Yale the answer is it's about twice the
cost of what we charge so even students
that are paying full price for their
their tuition at Yale and many students
are not but even those that are paying
full price are still being subsidized by
about 50 percent relative to the actual
cost of their education those that are
receiving substantial financial aid are
of course even further subsidized Yale
has been unique uh one of the really
handful of institutions
that is able to
attract students and admit students
irrespective of their of their ability
to pay
uh and so if you are a talented person
uh anywhere in the world and you want to
go to Yale and you can't your parents
can't afford it yeah we'll make that
possible and the endowment is critical
to that when you think of all the
people's lives that it has touched as an
institution they've gone on to make
contributions in their community in the
world it's an amazing thing
and what's really exciting about the
endowment today is that our plans at
Yale are so ambitious
we're trying to do things that will will
really change the world in really
meaningful ways you have brilliant
people at the institution who are
motivated to tackle some of the world's
most challenging problems and if you
want to fund people to take on new
challenges you have to keep increasing
your endowment our donors are you know
absolutely critical to the future of the
University they want to
fund efforts that will solve the great
mysteries of life and that will you know
really move the needle in terms of
profoundly changing the world our goal
is to support the University's mission
in perpetuity and we believe that
careful stewardship of the endowment is
critical to that mission that's what we
spend every day here thinking about
that's what my colleagues and I wake up
in the morning coming to the office to
do and that's why we're all here to give
back to you foreign
[Music]